If you found out that everyone in your town was
actually bloodthirsty vampires, what would you do?
Almost everyone you know is an undead monster
out for blood and no one is coming to save you.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made.
What you should do
and how to beat the vampires in Shiki.
This kid has no idea that bloodthirsty vampires
are coming to kill him.
Natsuno here has just discovered
a horrifying secret that all of the recent deaths
in his village have been caused
by terrifying vampires infecting men, women
and innocent children, causing them to die
and come back to life for blood.
Most of this town has already begun to turn,
and all of them now know that Natsuno.
And his buddies have figured out this town's
horrifying secret.
And everybody prepares
for the fight of their lives
Natsuno runs back home just as his family
tells him that a strange little girl
has stopped by to talk to him.
He goes to meet her in his room,
but she's nowhere to be found.
And this causes Natsuno, to freak out.
This kid's parents have no idea
what's really going on.
But Natsuno.
Knows that this little girl, along
with every other vampire within this village,
are going to attack this house tonight.
Okay, this is insane.
We've just found out that all of these deaths
in our village that we thought were
because of a virus
are actually because of vampires.
And this means that literally we need to focus on
preparing ourselves for the horrors soon
to come over
the last few months. Dozens of people died.
And if that means that all of them
turned into vampires,
that means there are literally dozens of vampires
walking around right outside.
And the fact that they just showed up in our house
means that our only home fortress is now at risk
because think about it.
Whichever vampire was in our room
could have snuck in through the window
and surprised, attacked us when we got home.
But since our joy of a parent's mention
to letting in a strange little girl,
that means they didn't sneak in.
They were let in by our stupid parents,
which more than likely means that this type
of vampire needs permission to enter our homes.
And while our home is now compromised,
at least we know this is a part of their weakness.
But nevertheless, our parents
don't have a clue about what's going on.
Nor would they likely believe us if we told them
about vampires taking over the village.
Because yeah, that would go over so well.
And unless we choose to leave our parents here
to eventually die, which we could do,
let's try and save them
because they seem like nice people.
I guess.
In this case, I take into account that Natsunos
Dad is some kind of woodworker or carpenter
based on what we've seen in his workshop.
With this in mind, I would wait for my parents
to head to bed first before
sneaking into his workshop, snag a bunch of tools
and make a whole crap ton of crosses.
And since this isn't an art competition,
they don't need to be perfect.
Which means I'll be able to make a lot of them
very quickly.
I would litter them all around
the outskirts of the house, hidden behind
whatever bush or object that prevents my parents
from seeing it and probably removing it,
which would ideally create
some sort of holy perimeter fence around the area.
But along with this,
I would also try and plant smaller wooden crosses
and stakes around the house, hidden
under the kitchen sink, under the living room
couch, and maybe even under their bed
and in their closet, if I am sneaky enough.
And then, for good measure,
I would place as many crosses
wherever I can, all over the house, in the off
chance a vampire or Shiki does attack us
while we're home. At the very least,
we have a fighting chance.
Now, realistically, this is a short term plan,
but as soon as daylight hits, we're okay,
we'll be fine.
And the first thing I'm going to do
is to get in touch with the town
doctor who has been at the front lines
investigating all of the deaths,
because realistically,
he knows way more than us right now,
and he's probably the only one who can break it
to our parents as to what's really going on.
We just have to survive tonight
and time is not on our side.
Natsuno gets ready for the horde of vampires
that's about to walk through his door
and he calls his friends
to tell them what has just happened.
He tells them that because his parents invited
a vampire in this house is no longer protected.
He tells this kid to not let his parents
invite anyone inside their house no matter what.
Meanwhile, Natsuno's Dad passes by his room
and sees all the crosses
and craziness and suddenly thinks that his son is
a bona fide weirdo.
Natsuno later comes back
to find all of his vampire protection taken down.
His dad tells him to chill out on the religion
and this forces Natsuno to protect his house
the old fashioned way by staying up
sharp and alert all night long.
He waits for death to come knocking on his door
just as he hears something banging outside.
A black figure suddenly appears,
but it has a familiar voice
that Natsuno, recognizes in shock.
It's his dead best friend, very much alive.
He cautiously opens the door and sees Toru,
who is now a bloodthirsty vampire.
He finds out that his best friend has been ordered
by the vampire boss to kill him.
But instead Toru tells Natsuno
to run from this town before it's too late.
He then disappears back into the forest
at lightning quick speed, Natsuno chases after
him, demanding answers right as he bumps into this
horrifying vampire boss, blue haired guy.
And he tells Natsuno that his plan to stop these
vampires is about to come to a horrifying end.
Blue haired guy prepares to kill him
right here, just as Toru slips behind him
and gives him some sheep to count.
The very next day, the town's doctor,
Toshio, struggles to plan his next move.
Just like Natsuno,
he knows this town is becoming more undead
by the day, but he's all out of ideas.
Just then, a whole mob appears outside,
led by this crazy lady.
This woman claims that she,
too, knows about the vampire secret and blames
everything on this family who moved in
right before all these horrors started.
She then drags a reluctant Toshio
and the mob begins
to bang on this family's castle doors,
just that this fancy Lord guy comes out
and the mob demands that Toshio checks
this guy's pulse to see if he is a vampire or not.
Okay, now, on the surface, while this seems like
a bad idea to call the crazy shaman lady crazy,
let's think about this for a second.
We still barely know how to kill these vampires
or what works or doesn't work on them.
This means that if we barely know anything yet
informing the village about the horrifying truth
will only make things worse.
Because right now, the vampires are killing off
villagers slowly and one by one,
and are obviously the most active at night,
which is when we, as humans
will be at our most vulnerable.
So if we tip off these vampires
that we actually know
what they are
and are going to do something about it
that's going to cause them
to accelerate their plans.
And we still don't know for sure where they sleep
or how effectively to kill them.
So the best method, while it sucks,
would be actually to do what Toshio is doing
right now until we figure out a proper plan
of how to deal with these things.
Play ball and don't cause
any trouble that we can avoid for now and also
for the sake of common sense.
Let's think about this for a second.
These vampires are probably centuries old,
which means they're more
than likely have dealt with the dozens,
if not hundreds of people over the years
who've gotten too close
to finding out their real secret.
Being a vampire means keeping this truth a secret,
at least
until they affect enough of the village's
population means they're not going to do anything.
For now, they probably know how to act normal
and how to trick the villagers into thinking
that they're just ordinary humans.
Toshio is actually going about this, right?
Because the only way to reveal the truth to
the townspeople
will be to catch the vampires with their undead
pants down when they least expect it.
Until then, we just need to play it cool.
Toshio checks fancy Lord Guy's pulse,
but is stunned to find out that he has a pulse.
This shocks the whole crowd,
who then goes home empty handed and out of ideas.
But Toshio knows that this guy is up to no good
and is working with the vampires somehow.
Elsewhere, these two kids
run into Natsuno with wild ideas
on how to save this town from horrifying vampires.
But something is not right with him,
and he shows them that he's been bitten.
It won't be long
before he turns into a terrifying monster himself.
Natsuno tells these kids to run far away from him
and never come back.
But he has no idea that these stupid bastards
will try to take on the vampire army themselves.
Later that night, Natsuno catches.
Toru, near his family's house
and he tries to convince his best friend to work
together with him, Natsuno thinks to vampires
and humans can live together in this town.
And he even offers to let Toru feed on him until
he figures out a proper plan to save this village.
But Toru is too hungry to listen and attacks
Natsuno without a second thought.
And he feasts on his best friend's
blood, forcing Natsuno to give up all hope.
He knows that he now can't save anybody,
and he soon will turn into the very thing
that took so many innocent lives the next day,
these two kids show up back Natsuno's door
and prepare to discuss their ongoing attack plans.
But that's when Natsuno.
Father answers the door
and gives them horrifying news.
He tells them that Natsuno is dead.
Okay, this is horrifying.
And now our only vampire hunting ally is dead.
This means we can no longer rely on anyone else
to put a stop to this except ourselves.
But let's be honest here.
We're kids
barely tall enough to ride a rollercoaster,
and the boy is barely man
enough to handle a Japanese shave kit.
So what are we really talking about here?
Our ally is dead and convincing our parents
at this point won't do much
because they won't believe any vampire story
we tell them until they see one for themselves,
which they won't believe in anyways.
And to top off the bad news, if the vampires get
us, that means we'll become one of them.
Which means we'll turn immortal and live forever.
Which sounds great at first to live forever.
But I don't know about you guys.
The thought of being stuck in a ten year
old's body forever sounds even more terrifying
than becoming a vampire itself. Think about it.
We won't ever be able to go watch an R-rated
movie, drive a car, fit in adult sized clothes.
We won't even be able to go to a bar
without somebody telling us we can be there.
Or worse,
try to talk to us in a very, very bad way.
This means it's even more terrifying
if we got turned into a vampire at this moment.
So we really got to think about
how to play our cards moving forward.
It's not clear of Natsuno
through his research taught the kids
everything he knows about vampires or chic,
but it's easy to assume that him caring for them
means that these kids would have already been told
something about how to protect themselves,
such as by wearing religious amulets
or being in possession of any type of holy relic,
if Natsuno, it didn't tell these kids
squat on how to protect themselves.
I would
then first try to study up on these creatures
the same way Natsuno did learn everything I can
about the various lore and mythological tales
throughout history that mentions these creatures,
but their house has likely already
been compromised.
Just like Natsuno's house.
The vampires or Shiki will find their way in
since they know where these kids live.
So if I were these snotty nose kids,
I would head back home, knock my mother out.
Sorry, Mom, and make sure that she goes
to sleep for a long time.
Tie her up, steal her
wallet and cash, and swiped the family truck
if they have one, and go straight
to another location
for a night or two, like a motel or something.
These kids need to hide
for a period of time out in a place
that is not their own registered address
and learn all that they can and what these vampire
bastards are and figure out their next move
and whether or not they should leave town.
And if so, where to?
Because realistically, being children,
this is their best bet
and only plan that they have right now.
Back at the clinic,
Toshio finds out that his wife, who came to visit
him, has also fallen dangerously sick.
But this doctor suddenly realizes
that his wife is the key to stopping the vampires.
He'll need to do something horrifyingly bad
to his wife if he wants to save this town,
and he prepares her to be his first vampire test
subject.
Meanwhile, these two kids suddenly find out
that the vampire virus has just killed their dad.
Their mom has no idea what's really going on
and calls the town's newly opened up health clinic
for help, but she has no idea of the horrors
that this health clinic is capable of.
Suddenly, a knock is heard at the front door
and this creepy old guy shows up
and he prepares to take their father down
to their health center called the Ibuchi Clinic.
Meanwhile, across town, Toshio begins
recording his fiance's vampire transformation
and begins committing the most horrifying
experiments on her to find out their weaknesses.
He discovers that these creatures are sensitive
to sunlight, have regenerative powers
and can't be harmed from poisons
and chemicals of any kind.
But suddenly this girl wakes up
shocked to find Toshio, killing her.
Slowly, she tries to break free
and begs for her precious life.
But Toshio ignores her completely and continues
to fiddle with his wife and not in the good way.
Okay, this is insane.
They got our dearly beloved
and forced us to clean up their mess.
Although it's about dang time
that we have our very own test subjects
and Toshio should have honestly done this way
sooner.
Basically,
the stuff that he's tried out on his wife
so far was something that you would find
in a kidnapper's daily work bag.
And he notes that general anesthesia
was not effective in working on his wife,
nor was another type of general anesthetic
that he used. And he even used morphine.
Basically.
So far, all the types of pain reliever
drugs have not worked on his vampire wife.
Which makes me think that even though
these creatures technically do not have
a pulse, their body due to the ineffectiveness
of the sedation drugs that Toshio just gave,
makes me think that their body
is still in some type of bio functioning state,
which allows their bodily processes to metabolize
of whatever poison or sedative that we give them.
This means that they're alive to some degree,
and it also means that the vampiric or Shiki
disease
could conform to the laws and physics of nature.
They're not cheeky or vampires
due to magic or some random crap,
but rather an actual disease
that causes them to possess traits of a vampire.
And in fact, what we see as a vampire
may not even be a vampire at all,
but a mere association with something
that we as a society began to link to vampires.
What I'm saying
is, is that this creature could be something else
entirely, such as a wendigo,
which is known to be a mythological creature
that is often associated and linked to that of a
werewolf, vampire, or some combination thereof.
It is possible that this creature is some undead
character that resembles a vampire but is not one.
And it's noted
that these creatures don't have pulses.
But Toshio does say
that as he cut into his vampiric wife's arteries,
that the blood flowing through her veins
suddenly stopped gushing blood,
meaning that somewhere else,
along within her artery, her body's
natural processes stopped the blood flow
almost immediately.
If the body stopped the blood gushing
when we cut into it, that means that
there was some blood flowing through to begin
with, despite them not having a pulse.
You see what I'm saying?
This could also mean
that what we're dealing with
could be a more primitive version
of what is known in folklore as a Hemomancer,
which is someone that can manipulate their blood
at will and as a weapon.
Now, I'm not saying that our wife is necessarily
a hemomancer or a Wendigo.
I'm just saying that maybe Toshio
and everyone else should not automatically assume
that just because these creatures
look like vampires means that they are vampires.
They could be a combination of different things
that could be a creature
of some other origin entirely.
And just like what's Natsuno did with his film
watching earlier.
I would look not to just folklore
or tales on vampires.
I would study up on various
different types of mythological beasts.
We're stepping out of the realm
of known sciences and creatures,
and by him conducting his practical experiments,
this may give us a more rounded
insight into what this thing
is, and, more importantly, how to beat it.
Like Frankenstein's monster, Toshio continues
to work on his monster to discover
any more vampire weaknesses that he can find,
realizing that even certain religious statues,
sounds and diagrams can hurt these
bloodsucking creatures if they're close enough.
Like a zombie,
he discovers that the only surefire way to kill
a vampire is by cutting off their head.
This is how you kill these undead monsters.
Toshio realizes that he's finally figured out
how to stop these things,
and he prepares his fiancee
for her final experiment with a stake
to the beating heart, silencing her
screams of pain and fear once and for all.
Mercy killing, of course.
But suddenly his vampire killing assistant
and best friend station stumbles into the room
and sees the horrors in the flesh.
He freaks out and thinks they're trying to save.
This town has turned to Toshio into a madman.
Later, Toshio continues his detective work
and discovers that while this virus has killed
dozens of people so far, none of them have really
died, at least according to the town's records.
This shocks Toshio as he realizes that everyone
working at this town center are all vampires.
Toshio stands paralyzed in fear as this office
worker tells him that
all the villager deaths that have happened
so far have happened outside of this town.
And that's how this village has managed
to keep its town death count to a zero, making
sure that no outside government or police force
finds out what's really going on in this town.
What is he doing
seeing all of these vampire employees
go about their work day means that this town
is not merely a buffet for these monsters
to feast from, but it actually has
all the workings of a town infiltration.
This means that these vampires or shiki
aren't making any noise,
and how they've been killing people
and now have begun the process of replacing
the entire town with their undead counterparts.
If they were just killing people,
it would be a lot easier on us
because it would be a lot harder
to hide the mounting pile of dead bodies.
It would be easier for us as humans
to leave the town
and get outside help as well as convince
the outsiders of what is really going on.
But since this town is already halfway
on the verge
of being replaced with basically vampires,
this means that even if we could get outside help,
we won't really be able to prove what's going on.
Because how could we prove to anyone
on the outside that people have been dying
and that vampires have taken over when literally
the town's death records are at zero?
Literally every single person
who is a vampire is still working all the jobs
that this little podunk town would have.
This whole situation is nuts. It's insane.
If I'm Toshio, I call this situation
a day and bounce.
Leave town immediately
without aggravating the things in this office.
Because it's clear
now that we are vastly outnumbered.
And here's why we should leave one
without any evidence.
We don't have a case.
And if we're dead, we can't present this case.
The only last minute resort I would do before
bouncing out
and getting out of Dodge would be to create
some sort of big enough of a draw
to have outside attention come in.
Because remember, this town
has been described as being isolated and cut off
from the rest of the country for the most part.
And so our best and only card left to draw from
would be in the form of a wild card.
We set off a bunch of forest fires
and also create a bunch of explosions of some kind
big enough to kill at least a few innocent people.
I'm sorry, but it's for the greater good.
And in doing this,
I think this will be the most effective
method to draw that outside attention in
because the vampires or shiki up
until now have been very methodical
with how they've kept the death count to zero.
But I ask you this
how will it look when all of a sudden
a large number of people suddenly die
within the town due to a sudden explosion?
This will look suspicious as hell and will
no doubt attract attention from outside forces
and will influence the outside factors
that these Shiki will be unable to predict.
I'm not saying this plan will necessarily
defeat the shiki
but it will take away some of the control
that these things have been exerting on this town
so far.
However, if we want to seal the deal that outside
help does come, all we have to do
is this leave town as soon as possible.
Go to a highly populated area,
and then make an anonymous call
telling the authorities that there's going to be
a series of bombs going off in our village.
And we were the ones that made them
well, let a few hours go by
and let the first of our explosives go off.
We'll call again informing them
that the first explosive has just gone off.
This will make sure that the authorities
are taking this seriously
and get their behinds over to our village.
A little bit extreme, yes, but totally worth it.
Enraged Toshio threatens to expose them all.
But then suddenly he hears someone talking to him
and turns around.
He sees a horrifying vampire lord guy's girl.
She introduces herself as Chizuru
and tells Toshio that he better stop
his vampire killing quest, or else she'll let
all of the Shiki in here eat him for dinner.
Right here, right now.
But she doesn't want to do that,
as she likes to feed exclusively on virile
young men just like him.
So she lets him go for now.
Elsewhere, another death in the village takes
place and the bodies rack up at the Ibuchi clinic.
But no one here realizes that this strange clinic
is where their dead come back to life.
And this group of savage monsters begins
recruiting more and more members.
Toshio begins losing hope as all of his nurses
quit and leave the clinic for good, saying
that they don't even recognize him anymore.
But all of a sudden something insane shows up
right at Toshio's doorstep.
Natsuno, back from the dead.
And he briefly stops by to let Toshio know that
he's not alone in this fight and tells them that
the only way to stop these horrifying monsters
will be to catch them with their pants down.
The next morning, these kids
find out that just like their father,
their mother has just died, which angers the duo.
And this is the last straw.
But this kid especially thinks he's more man
than boy and runs off to fight solo
last minute, roaming the streets with rage
and fury, he finds what looks like an abandoned
and closed off building.
But he thinks this is the secret home
for a vampire or Shiki nest.
He runs inside without any backup like an idiot
and finds a single sleeping vampire one
whisper away from waking up
with nothing to lose anymore He prepares to kill
this bastard here and now, but suddenly fudges
it up and gets knocked out later that day.
Natsuno shows up again to speak with Toshio
and mentions of a plan to reveal to this village
the existence of vampires once and for all.
Using the up and coming town festival
as the perfect opportunity, he tells Toshio that
they must kill them all, including him,
and the two get to work on their final plan.
But the next day couldn't be more horrifying,
as Toshio wakes up exhausted
as hell and finds the Grim Reaper
standing right in front of him, CHIZURU.
Toshio tries to kill her,
but his stake is suddenly shot from the window
by cheesy ruse helper Lord.
The guy Toshio then suddenly declares
that he's done trying to help ungrateful people,
and now that he is finally ready
to walk over to the dark side, Chizuru
is delighted to hear this as she gets her
little man toy and bites on his sweet flesh
and she puts him under her spell
and orders him to destroy all of his vampire
research and obey her from now on.
Later that day, blue haired guy arranges
a meeting with the Natsuno.
Unlike everybody else, he knows that
this kid is unique and is not obeying
any orders and mentions to Natsuno that
he already knows that his just like blue hair.
The guy Natsuno has turned into something more
than just a normal Shiki or a vampire.
Basically, he's turned into a Jinro, a vampire,
basically like Blade
stronger, faster than any ordinary shiki
and can survive the sun.
But these creatures still need to feed on human
flesh in order to maintain their powers.
And he can tell that Natsuno
hasn't fed on anything.
Blue haired guy tells Natsuno that if he doesn't
join the vampire side soon he'll die
and he leaves. Natsuno,
to think about his horrifying offer.
Okay, this is insane.
What blue haired guy is basically saying
is that him and Natsu are part
of a subspecies of vampire that basically function
like blade from the Marvel Comics.
All of the benefits of a vampire
with no real weaknesses.
Unlike regular poo poo Shiki,
these guys transform right at the brink of death.
Technically,
never actually dying, just transforming.
This could explain
how their physiology differs than regular Shiki
who only transform after their human death.
And if we look carefully, blue haired guy
as a Jinro has been calm as balls
throughout this entire situation up until now.
Jinroan General have a brain that functions much
more similar to that of a human, allowing them
to have all the ruthlessness and power that comes
with being a Shiki, along with being able
to control their emotions perfectly, being able
to survive out in the sun and live on human food.
But the fact that blue haired guy just lost
his cool here makes me think that we can use this
if we're able to enrage him in some way
and make him react to a situation
on instinct and feelings rather than logic.
Have you ever seen an animal lose their shit?
That's the plan here.
In this sense, I would begin by considering any
and all things that blue haired guy cares about,
such as white haired chick Chizuru herself.
If we can find a way for someone
to hold her hostage and hurt her in front of blue
haired guy, I think we could have a real shot
at angering him to the point where his rage clouds
his judgment, allowing us to kill both of them,
which would devastate the Shiki side,
or even more ideally, by holding Chizuru hostage,
we'll be able to bend a blue haired guy
to our will.
Also, if I was a Jinro like Natsuno,
I'd spend less time moping around and dressed
like a golf boy and would spend more time
trying to understand just how powerful I can be
as a Shiki-vampire Hybrid.
Natsuno should take some time now while he's free
and test out his powers by himself,
he could get super creative and kidnap a regular
week or Shiki vampire to test his powers on.
He'll be able to channel his inner psychopath
and make this Shiki his little plaything.
I'm just saying, he's got to get a move on
and figure out his powers ASAP.
Back at the clinic, Toshio now under Chizuru
mind control reports to her that he's destroyed
all of his vampire research.
He suddenly notices the lights
from the town festival in the distance
and suggests that they should pay the festival
a visit.
And Chizuru agrees
on the way she tells Toshio all about their evil
plan to take over this entire village
and use it as a central hub.
These creatures are tired of hiding
and their plan is almost complete.
Toshio
then says that celebrations are then in order
and he promises to show her a night
that she'll remember forever.
They then meet a bunch of the villagers
when all of a sudden
Chizuru sees the temple statues nearby
and she begins freaking out, wanting to go home.
She demands that Toshio obey her orders,
but Toshio does it to listen.
She realizes that the impossible has happened,
and that Toshio is somehow
no longer under her spell.
A villager
all of a sudden notices her dead cold skin,
and Toshio says that she's fallen dangerously ill
and that she needs to go to rest.
In the office nearby, Chizuru starts freaking out,
but that's when she notices something insane.
On Toshio's neck.
She sees an older bite mark on his neck
that isn't hers, but not Sumo's.
Meaning that Toshio has always been
Natsuno's slave, not hers.
This was their plan all along.
Toshio finally yells out the horrifying truth
in front of everybody that she's through
here is an okiyagari, a Shiki or vampire,
forcing these villagers to check her pulse.
And one by one,
everyone realizes the horrifying truth.
This guy suddenly steps in and the gang
brutally murders Chizuru right here and now.
Toshio then reveals to everyone here
that the whole vampire story, who they are,
what's really going on in this village
and how to kill them.
And he prepares
all of these people for the hunt of their lives
and they try to take back their town.
Okay, this is some next level type stuff.
I'm talking like Evian, water type of bull crap.
We finally have the villagers on our side,
which is great,
and the entire town is almost under the vampires
thumbs, which is not so great.
Here's what we're going to do.
We're not going to go to the police,
even the police in another town nearby.
That won't work
as we have little evidence to show them.
Unlike these townsfolk who now know, thanks
to Chizuru being dead, they finally believe us.
But here's the thing.
If we want to play it smart, I'm going to tell
all these townsfolk to let it be until morning.
If we're going to hunt these things,
we're going to do it right, because most of them
will be forced to hide from the sun,
which will definitely increase
our odds of survival and help us in finding them,
because they're not going to be able
to wander around all that much.
We're going to hunt them down
while the sun is out.
Not right now, while it's night.
That will give the Shiki an advantage if we do
and would only result in more human deaths.
I would tell the villagers to all stay right here
and park it right next to those temple statues.
Though Shiki seem unable to handle
being near those things, which is great for us.
So we're all going to stay right
near those things until morning.
Well, pick out some of the civilians
who are more capable
than others and rotate out throughout the night
allowing everybody to get some form of rest
while still having some people on the lookout
in case some shiki come by to visit early morning.
The next day, the news of Chizuru,
whose death reaches the mansion
and seating here, says that the villagers
will most likely come for their throats.
Next, blue haired guy says that they should leave
town, but this annoying little bloodsucker called
Sunako says that they have nowhere to go,
so all they can do now is survive.
But this little girl is the Shiki boss and orders
blue haired guy to go cut off the snake's head.
But now leader of the humans, Toshio.
But it's already too late.
The sun has begun to rise and these villagers
have already stormed the vampire mansion.
Blue haired guy quickly tells Seishin to go
watch over Sunako as he leaves to go kill Toshio
the villagers start killing every single
bloodsucking bastard they see it's a bloodbath.
Meanwhile, Toshio tells the villagers
to bury all of these vampires.
So no outside police force ever discovers them.
But something is not right.
And Toshio tells this beard to do that,
there should be seven more Shiki hiding somewhere
and thinks that they must be hiding
within the town's underground tunnels.
They gather outside and prepare to go down
through those tunnels when all of a sudden
this rando is shot dead by Lord Guy,
hearing the shots
Natsuno rushes in to try and stop him,
but suddenly gets shot by Lord Guy and he escapes.
Okay,
this is some authentic microwave pasta from Italy.
type of bullshit.
This Lord guy should have been stopped since way
back since from the very fact that he is human.
And Toshio,
being the one who actually examined him
earlier, means that Natsuno
could have been informed
of this Lord guy way earlier,
when he actually could have stopped him before
he just killed this dude.
And even then, Natsuno
could have just snuck up on him
without announcing his presence like an idiot.
And now we're presented with a huge problem
humans empathetic to vampires
who want to help them either
because they feel sorry for them
or they want to become just like them.
And that is a problem that we cannot have.
Not right now. So here's what we're going to do.
Beard Guy will be in charge of one group
of townsfolk, Toshio
in charge of another,
and we will be in charge of another one
by breaking up the townsfolk into three groups
and placing
strong leaders at the head of each group.
This will help reduce the risk
that the people who are squishy towards the Shiki,
the ones who will not kill them or even worse
help them, will be able to influence the rest
of the townsfolk into not doing what must be done.
And we can even take this one step further
by having Beard Guy Toshio and us
look for the person in each of their own group
who hates the Shiki the most and make that person
their second in command, which will then allow us
to split up the townsfolk even more
and reduce the possibility of the squashes
taking over even further.
And this will help establish a clear
chain of command and allow us to kill the Shiki
more effectively.
Back at the castle, blue haired guy
realizes that he can take on this many people
on his own and slips back into the shadows.
He finds Seishin and Sunako and tells them
that almost all of their kind has been wiped out,
meaning
this group is running out of time to escape.
But Toshio and his army of ordinary killers
begin to realize that their winning streak
is about to come to a horrifying end.
If they don't speed up their mission.
This guy tells Toshio that people
from the next town over have started to wonder
why all the roads into this town
have been blocked, and that the deliverymen
and drivers have been unable to enter this town.
They're running out of time.
People are asking too many questions
about what's really going on in this town.
Toshio then realizes that they must kill every
single shiki here by the next morning or out.
Some of them will escape for good.
But Toshio doesn't realize
that the killing is about to get.
Oh, so much worse.
This guy suddenly reports that some of
the villagers have begun killing other humans.
Humans who they thought were under a Shiki spell.
And this makes the rest of these villagers realize
that they can't trust anybody and must kill
anyone who gets in their way,
even their very own friends and neighbors.
And now this group of hungry killers
head down into the sewers
to kill the last remaining Okiyagari
that are you that are hiding even the scared ones.
And now both sides fight for their lives.
The whole town has gone nuts and it's a bloodbath.
Countless humans and vampires
get brutally murdered within minutes, and these
villagers drag the last remaining vampires out and
chained them to these trees, watching them burn.
And they sing beautiful songs
to mask their horrifying screams.
Even Lord Guy gets found and hypnotized
by Natsunot to burn himself alive.
The screams have now reached the burning vampire
mansion, and underneath its structure, blue
haired guy finally comes up with a plan to help
Sunako and Seishin escape ordering them
to sneak into this car and drive out the back
and he'll distract the villagers.
But outside, Toshio and the villagers accidentally
discover Seishin on the run and chase him down.
Just then, his car comes to a horrifying
halt, Seishin now badly injured
drag Sunako in this briefcase
around the mountain houses and temples.
And he hides and watches his innocent parents
get brutally murdered by their very own neighbors.
This horrifies
poor Seishin desperate and losing blood fast.
He hide soon to go under this rock and leads
the villagers the other way.
But he suddenly passes out and leaves
poor Sunako out in the open,
just as these hunters realize
that their precious town is going up in flames.
This old guy tells
the rest to go get help from Toshio
and he decides to handle little Sunako himself.
Meanwhile, Toshio gathers
the terrified townsfolk and tells them to dump
all of the bodies into the fire
and to leave this town for good
because nobody can find out what went down
in this village right near the fire,
a badly injured blue haired guy tries
to escape this town as one of the last shiki
or vampires have left alive.
But he runs into Natsuno
whose plan has all come together.
The two Jinro battle it out for a horrifying
last stand, but Natsuno, gets beaten to a bloody
pulp and falls into a vampire gravesite.
On his deathbed,
blue haired guy prepares to kill him
until he sees Natsuno explosive package
and he blows up blue haired guy all the way down.
To hell with him.
Okay,
this is some overpriced Benihana type of bullcrap.
No, it's an ocean out of offed himself the way
he did and his annoying, emo, self-hating persona.
Having someone alive from the Jinro species
meant that he could have done wonders
for the benefit of humanity in the form of helping
us advance in medical innovations.
Since we could have found out
so much in terms of how his vampire body works
and how it could benefit the human race.
Toshio is a medical man.
He should have taken note of that.
Natsuno self-hating ways
meant that he was going to off himself
after this vampire crusade was over,
especially after Natsuno literally said to Toshio,
Hey, make sure you kill me after this is all done.
Toshio should have taken the hint and tied him up.
Beef Wellington style,
just like Gordon Ramsay down in his basement.
And from there Toshio could keep experimenting
on Toshio all for the good of humanity.
Elsewhere, the fire has engulfed the entire town,
and soon a cow finally collapses
in this building, exhausted as hell.
But old guy is in far behind
and he picks her up and he readies his stake.
But suddenly he gets killed by, Seishin
who is now a Shiki back from the dead.
Ashamed of all of the deaths.
Sunako gets ready to die right here in, but
say she convinces her that she's a good person.
All the while, as Toshio and the rest
of the survivors escape at their destroyed
town Seishin escapes
with Sunako into the bosom of a new dawn.